president Trump kicked off the holiday
weekend by celebrating the nation's
independence with a grand act of
defiance going against the advice of
doctors including the White House
coronavirus task force the President and
First Lady did not wear masks when they
greeted some 7,000 spectators who
gathered for speeches and fireworks last
night at the base of Mount Rushmore
earlier a group of Native American
protesters were arrested after they
blocked a road leading to the monument
while mr. Trump thanked first responders
for their efforts to battle the virus
his 40-minute speech largely took aim at
the efforts to remove controversial
monuments and statues
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning what more can you tell us
hey good morning to you Michelle and
happy fourth President Trump and the
first lady just got back to the White
House from South Dakota a short time ago
and while last night's event was about
celebrating the country the president
instead used much of his speech to take
a hard line against those he accuses of
trying to tear it down
[Music]
as fireworks lit up over Mount Rushmore
for the first time in a decade
president Trump delivered a fiery
defense of the founding fathers I am
here as your president to proclaim
before the country and before the world
this monument will never be desecrated
these heroes will never be defense their
legacy will never ever be destroyed the
president lashed out at protesters
seeking to remove controversial
historical figures from their place on
pedestals our nation is witnessing a
merciless campaign to wipe out our
history to fame our heroes erase our
values and indoctrinate our children
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. Trump announced a new executive
order creating a national garden to
feature statues of American heroes we
are the country of Andrew Jackson
alyssia's s grant and Frederick Douglas
at the event there was little space for
social distancing organizers offered
masks but few in the crowd put them on
and now coronavirus has entered the
president's Family Circle kimberly
guilfoyle the girlfriend of Donald Trump
jr. tested positive for the virus the
president's son tested negative the pair
were in South Dakota for a fundraiser
but sources say have not been in direct
contact with the president and tonight
President Trump will headline a salute
to America here at the White House
complete with military flyovers and more
fireworks the mayor of Washington has
cited public health risks and is urging
residents to stay home but for those who
don't the National Park Service is
making some 300-thousand masks available
to visitors along the National Mall chef
Nicole thank you very much